les plantations de canne à sucre font
partie du paysage de la côte ouest de
l'île la plante est souvent récolté à la
main à l'aide du sabre par les coupeurs
de cad les retenues d'eau sont
principalement alimentés par les eaux
pluviales et les ruisseaux
elles sont utilisées pour l'irrigation
des cultures et permettent aux
agriculteurs d'assurer les rendements de
nombreuses ravines lasserre les reliefs
entre la côte à cilaos elles font partie
du paysage du grenier de la réunion
surnom donné par les locaux à la région
au nord de l'antre 2 à l'ouest du cirque
de cilaos dimitile ou une zone déserte
au réputé dans les années 1950 pour sa
production d'huile essentielle de
géranium
oh